soldiers from South Sudan's opposition
celebrate their return to the capital
Juba it's a historic moment for these
men who haven't set foot in the town
since the conflict first erupted their
arrival brings hope that a peace process
is finally taking hold
but despite the optimism tensions are
running high amid regular ceasefire
violations and concerns that government
and opposition forces might clash again
to avoid confrontations the government
army the SPLA pledged to move most of
its troops outside the city something
the opposition says hasn't been done now
come and see our position you know the
number that arrived today we have
ordered a revolution we show to you the
forces but for the poor there's really
tangata still inside the box everything
is still intact you can see when the
detachment the forces are deployed all
over the city the government on the
other hand claims it has completed the
withdrawal of forces to sites such as
this one located at least 25 kilometers
outside of Juba but this has yet to be
verified by independent monitors we have
a total of nine redeployment sites this
is just one of them so we sent out an
invitation to that monitoring mechanism
telling them that desperella is ready
for verification
despite the cautious optimism
surrounding much ours return many South
Sudanese don't really trust that peace
is really coming over 28,000 displaced
persons mostly from Achara snow air
tribe are still seeking safety inside
this camp on the outskirts of Juba
guarded by United Nations peacekeepers
we are very happy to receive Riek Machar
and we are happy to see the opposition
forces here but we don't really know
what will happen after he comes back if
there will really be
pease matures return is just the first
step on a long road towards reforms
reconstruction and ultimately
reconciliation of communities that have
been torn apart by the conflict until
that happens many inside this UN camp
don't trust their country is safe enough
to return home